President Trump you know he made a
mistake last week a mistake that people
could make little slip of the tongue a
little Freudian slip he does specialize
in getting he specializes them and he
can't let it grow and he's even tweeting
about it this today yeah yeah today he's
tweeting about still it happened last
week if you didn't know about this last
week President Trump called Apple CEO
Tim Cook Tim Apple you hear the laugh
that got that's a real thing the
president said and it's gonna do better
than anything I say tonight no he did he
was a said he called him Tim Apple which
makes no sense that's like me like any
it's like if I called you and II
sidekick
it is like that Conan paycheck
that's all you see when you look at me
yes I see the taller brother of Johnny P
exactly Trump was not the only one
tweeting this week did you hear about
Jose Canseco's tweet sure about that yes
they did Alex Rodriguez and Jennifer
Lopez got engaged this weekend and when
word got out former baseball star Jose
Canseco started tweeting at JLo that a
rod has been cheating on him yeah are
cheating on her sorry yeah it's been a
rough weekend
no seriously he'll say consejo just try
to tweet it's crazy these are these were
not made up these are his real tweets
check it out Alex Rodriguez stop being a
piece of [ __ ] stop cheating on Jennifer
Lopez these are real then he tweeted
this watching world of dance watching
JLo text editor Alex Rodriguez little
does she know that he is cheating on her
with my ex-wife Jessica poor girl she
has no idea who he really is gets
crazier he also sent this at JLo if you
want the truth about Alex Rodriguez call
me those are real used his real phone he
used his real his real phone number I
don't know what to make of any of this
we looked into it and it turns out this
is not the first time Jose Canseco has
tried to warn people via Twitter for
example a couple of weeks ago he tweeted
Kim jong-un is building more nuclear
weapons at POTUS call me yeah that's it
that's yeah then Benny tweeted Bob Kraft
is looking a little horny could be
trouble at Patriots call me
in January he tweeted yo at Kevin Hart
for real hashtag Oscars coming up delete
old tweets call me then right after
right after the Oscars he tweeted dear
at Bradley Cooper's current girlfriend
they did it call me then last Friday he
tweeted hey at Cosi Canseco you're about
to send a bunch of tweets you'll really
regret call you and finally he just
tweeted Conan hiding his midlife crisis
behind a new casual look at TBS call me
[Applause]